today will take over 140,000 data points
of people being killed or injured by
guns and visualize them with deck GL and
Google Maps we can go from a heat map of
the entire country down to the actual
street view of a neighborhood where the
[ __ ] went down we'll start by adding a
scatter plot layer for every single
point in the data set then we'll add a
tool tip to see how many people were
injured or killed at a given incident
and we'll cluster points together into a
heat map based on the map zoom level
lastly we'll cluster points into a
hexagon with a one-mile radius and
extrude them into a 3d shape where the
elevation represents the amount of
violence in that space we can do all of
this data visualization efficiently
thanks to a library called deck GL it
was created by uber to visualize their
own data and is able to run computations
efficiently by offloading them to the
GPU with WebGL take a look at their
showcase for some awesome examples of
companies using this technology in
production I think my favorite is escape
it uses the deck GL arc layer to
visualize the cheapest flights based on
your location around the world now I
realize that guns are a hot political
issue in the United States
so I've tried to make this visual as
neutral as possible the data comes from
the gun violence archive from the years
2013 to 2018 on the live demo you can
filter by defensive u suicide and so on
to get a better picture of how the data
is distributed before we get started
let's talk you a little bit more about
how Dec GL works you can think of it as
a layer or multiple layers that sit on
top of your google map when the user
pans around or zooms in and out the
overlay will stick to the map and an
awesome thing about this is that the
layers can be composited in other words
you can set layers on top of each other
add some transparency and Dec GL will
calculate the composite colors that are
actually rendered on the screen and that
can give you some amazing 3d visuals on
top of a two-dimensional map the actual
JavaScript library itself follows the
reactive programming paradigm so it's
very simple and familiar to most
front-end developers all you really need
is a good data set a Google Maps API key
a few lines of JavaScript and you'll be
up and running with interactive 3d
visuals on top of your map the first
thing you'll need to get started is a
Google Maps API to create a new project
or use the existing project on the
Google
platform console from there go to the
API screen you'll find the Google Maps
JavaScript API enable it and then go to
the credentials tab and grab your
browser API key just make a note of the
API key for now we'll need it in a
minute or so when we get into the code
you can use deck GL in any framework but
it provides additional support for react
in this video I'm going to use vanilla
JavaScript with webpack and we'll set it
up with hot module replacement for a
nice developer experience go ahead and
open up vs code and keep in mind you can
find all of these steps in this lesson
on fire ship io first to run npm init
with the why flag to set up a new NPM
project then we'll install web pack and
web pack dev server into the development
environment from there I'll open up the
package JSON and I'm going to add a
couple of scripts that we can use to
build and serve the app the build
command runs web pack and outputs
everything into the public folder which
is where we'll actually put our
production code then the start command
will use webpack dev server to serve
that code locally on localhost 8080 and
it will also perform hot module
replacement whenever our source code
changes the next thing we'll do is
install deck GL it's organized in a mono
repo so there's different packages that
you may or may not need we're going to
need the Google Maps package layers and
aggregation layers the next thing we'll
do is create a file for our JavaScript
source code in the source directory and
a little vs code pro tip here is to
create that file with a slash and it
will automatically create the directory
structure for you and then we'll do the
same thing for the public HTML file then
inside this HTML we'll just start with a
plain HTML document and we'll make a
reference to the main J's file which is
where web pack will build our source
code after that we'll add a deferred
script tag for the Google Maps
JavaScript API this script has two
required parameters the first one is the
API key which is the browser API key
that you got from the Google cloud
platform console and the callback is the
name of a function defined on the window
that initializes the map with whatever
options you want to pass to it will
define that one in just a minute in our
JavaScript code then the last thing we
want to do is go into the body of the
HTML and add a div with an ID of map
this div will be replaced by the actual
Google map and in our case we want to
display a full-screen map so we'll use
some CSS to set the width and height to
100
percent of the viewport now we'll go
ahead and open up our javascript file
and we'll want to define a function on
the window object this is the callback
that we set on the Google Maps script
tag the first argument is the actual div
that will be replaced by the map so
we'll go ahead and get that by its ID
and then you can add a bunch of
additional options here depending on how
you want to customize your app in fact
Google provides a wizard that helps you
quickly customize the appearance of your
map that's how I created the dark map
that you see in the demo so now that we
have this init map function on the
window we can run NPM start to tell web
pack to build our code that will also
spin up a server on localhost 8080 so if
you navigate there you should see the
default map at this point and your code
should rebuild anytime you update and
save the index.jsp
now that we have this initial set up out
of the way we need to get some actual
data to display on the map now this can
be very easy or very difficult depending
on the data you're working with if you
want to go the easy route you can simply
grab the JSON data that lives on my web
server but since you're a developer I'm
assuming you want to use your own custom
data a great place to find free data
that's already well formatted is from
Kaggle datasets but in most cases this
data is going to be in CSV format an
easy way to convert this data to the
proper format is to use the node package
convert csv to json from there create a
file called convert GIS and the root of
your project then inside the script we
can create a very simple node script
that has an input in CSV format and then
an output and JSON now we can just run
that script from the command line and
we've magically converted our custom
dataset into JSON format that we can use
with deck GL your data should be an
array of JSON objects so in our case it
looks like this the property names on
this object can be anything you want so
you don't really need to format your
data in any special way because as
you'll see in the code we tell Dec GL
exactly how to access this data let's
move into our index j s file and we'll
import Google Maps overlay as well as
the layers that we want to display from
deck GL now like I said earlier deck GL
uses a reactive programming paradigm so
I like to create my layers inside of a
function anytime your map or data
changes you tell Dec GL to rebuild the
entire map under the hood it's looking
at the diff to update things efficiently
very similar to react J s it can do that
because every layer is required to have
a unique
and Dec GL uses that to track the
changes for that specific layer the next
option that you'll need to pass is the
data so in our case this will just be
the path to the local JSON file but this
could also be a remote URL or a promise
that resolves to the JSON object now
every layer has a variety of optional
parameters that you can pass to
customize the way the points are
displayed
things like opacity and pixel radius are
pretty self-explanatory
now for every point in the data set Dec
GL is going to call the function that
you pass to get position so get position
is very similar to a for each loop where
D represents an individual object in the
data set the function needs to return an
array of the longitude point and the
latitude point in that order it's not
latitude longitude like you might see in
other map programs it's the more
mathematically correct format of X Y you
can also use functions to compute other
properties like the actual fill color on
the scatterplot in this case I'm looking
at if the number of people killed in
this incident is greater than zero in
which case I'll make the dot red
otherwise I'll make it orange which
means that there are only injuries and
that's all it takes to define a scatter
plot layer from there I'm going to jump
down into the anit map function that we
wrote earlier we'll define a variable
called overlay that's equal to a Google
Maps overlay instance and it takes an
array of layers that will be stacked on
top of each other so we'll go ahead and
add our scatter plot function there then
the final step is to add overlay set map
with the actual Google Maps instance so
that's how we initialize a map for the
first time if you're running updates on
a map you would call set props with any
subsequent updates to the same map I
just wanted to point that out but we're
actually not going to use it in this
simplified demo from here if you open
the browser you should see all the
points plotted on the map but I'd like
to make these a little more interactive
by adding a tooltip when the user hovers
over an individual point we can do that
by setting the pickable option to true
on the scatter plot layer and then from
there we'll define a function that runs
on the on hover event this will give us
access to the actual data object that
represents that point and then also it's
XY coordinates we'll grab an element
from the Dom called tooltip and then if
an object exists we'll go ahead and
insert some HTML into that tooltip based
on the actual data object and if an
object does not exist
we'll simply hide the tooltip by setting
its opacity to zero
and you can also handle click events so
if the user clicks on a given point we
can take them to the actual instant
report on gun violence archive now I
problem with the map currently is that
it's kind of hard to visualize a hundred
and forty thousand points all at once
fortunately Dec GL has aggregation
layers that will cluster the points into
meaningful shapes this time let's go
ahead and create a function that returns
a heat map layer this function uses the
same getter for position and we also
have the option to calculate the weight
for each point by default every data
point has a weight of 1 but we want to
weight the data points based on how
violent the incident was so we'll go
ahead and take the number of people
killed in that incident and then add it
to the number of people injured times
0.5 so you get the most points for
killing people but you also get bonus
points for injuring people as well we'll
go ahead and set the pixel radius to 60
and then we could also customize colors
here as well but we'll just go ahead and
skip that for now and lastly we'll come
down here and add the heat map to our
layers you can see I've switched the map
to dark mode to see things a little bit
better and you'll notice we get
different clustering patterns based on
the zoom level of the map if we zoom in
all the way we'll start to see the
individual instance that make up the
larger clusters the heat map is useful
but we may want to cluster our points
based on a specific boundary and a great
way to do that is with the hexagon layer
this allows us to cluster points into a
specific radius and then increase its
elevation in the third dimension based
on how violent that area is we can do
that by defining a getter for the
elevation weight using the same logic
that we used in the previous example we
can customize the appearance with a
variety of different parameters and you
can even use your own algorithm to
control how the points are clustered
into the hexagons go ahead and add
hexagons to the layers and you'll now
see that we get these extruded shapes on
the map we can look at the elevation of
the hexagons to determine how violent
that neighborhood is and the color of
the hexagon becomes more red as the
violence increases now we've barely only
scratched the surface on what's possible
with Dec GL if you need high-performance
data visualization on a large dataset
it's definitely worth checking out I'm
gonna go ahead and wrap things up there
if this video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member at fire ship IO for access to
even more content thanks for watching
and I will talk to you soon
[Music]
[Music]